offrir aux familles d'enfants malades
des moments de vie partagée c'est le but
de l'association les cahutes de Louise
Louise du nom de cette adolescente
décédée en 2021 d'une leucémie séparant
veulent aujourd'hui que les enfants
hospitalisés à Tours puissent se changer
les idées quelques jours avec leurs
proches dans des lieux marquants comme
le château de Chambord voyez ce
reportage d'elen
c'est un petit coin de verdure et de
tranquillité à quelques centaines de
mètres du château de Chambord dans le
jardin potager du domaine à l'ombre des
arbres 3 cahut en bois ont
temporairement été installés Aria 4 ans
en profite pour se détendre et jouir à
la princesse avec sa famille elle va
passer une semaine ici un séjour
totalement gratuit proposé par
l'association les cahutes de Louise une
parenthèse offerte à tous ceux qui ont
un enfant atteint d'une maladie
chronique
on ne pouvait pas partir cette année
puisqu'on était sur la fin des
traitements pour Aria et il faut qu'on
reste à proximité de l'hôpital pendant
encore quelques mois donc l'écueil de
Louise sont les bienvenus pour nous
c'est important ça nous donne
l'opportunité de pouvoir changer d'air
nous évader un petit peu et puis être un
petit peu loin de l'hôpital et tous ces
soins
aujourd'hui à Chambord en septembre au
château de Chenonceau les cahuttes vont
terminer leur première saison au domaine
de Candé en novembre prochain 5 mois
d'activité et près d'une trentaine de
familles de la région accueillies sur
des sites prestigieux
évidemment comme tout démarrage de
projet
il faut
il faut réussir à convaincre il se
trouve que là la cause est noble donc
déjà c'était c'était un point positif
pour pour mes démarches auprès des sites
d'accueil
c'est vrai que
les premiers à m'avoir dit oui ça a été
le domaine de Candé et que quand il y a
un site qui vous dit oui et ben il est
plus facile d'avoir
d'autres sites
il reste des places pour venir passer
une ou plusieurs nuits dans ces cahutes
écologiques et autonomes et accéder au
monument qui les accueillent pour plus
de renseignements direction le site les
cahutes de louise.org